foreign minister good of you to take the
time this afternoon thank you so much
for joining us here on sky news
thank you for having me good evening um
a lot more diplomacy going on this week
western leaders are getting together to
talk about what more they can do to help
ukraine i know that the us secretary of
state anthony blinken visited your
country yesterday and the discussion was
about just that what more can countries
like estonia do what was the outcome of
those discussions
yesterday we had very important
discussions with secretary uh blink and
how the international community could
support the end of the war in ukraine
which was unjustifiedly started by
russia
and of course we must continue to
support ukraine politically economically
continue to give humanitarian aid to
ukraine but also defensive means at the
same time it is very important to
pressure the russian federation to stop
this unjustified and very unfortunate
war which is totally
unacceptable because it is severe
violation of the international law
severe violation of
security related agreements of europe
can you talk to me about
there's
there's a bit of confusion today over
supplying jets to ukraine which they
have asked for and poland thought it had
come up with a solution it wanted to
send jets to germany and then they would
be sent on to ukraine but the united
states says that was untenable
because it would be
perhaps seen as an act of aggression by
the west and nato
towards russia it's a very sensitive
time in what kind of support you do and
do not offer to ukraine what line do you
think there is in what you can offer
them why can't you offer them jets
it is very important to continue provide
continue to provide defensive equipment
to ukraine so that they could protect
their country
and so far we have seen that more than
20 countries already have provided
defensive equipment to uh ukraine for me
it is very difficult to comment the
decisions of other countries but what
can i what i can say that estonia itself
does not fight does not have fighters to
provide but we have provided and donated
this kind of defensive equipment what we
could
deliver and estonia has already
supported ukraine
with
defensive equipment for the about uh 200
million euros it is a big support for
ukraine and we very much welcome that
also other countries have provided
different defensive means for ukraine
which have been possible for them
yeah a lot being made of the fact that
what is being supplied by nato members
and western nations are
defensive weapons um
at what point
is that not enough because president
zielenski every time we hear from him
every time he makes an appeal to western
leaders it's about wanting more what if
those defensive weapons aren't enough
for ukraine
here of course it is a very important to
speak about the main goal the main goal
is to help to end this war and therefore
we the western countries we are trying
to support of course ukraine with
defensive equipment so that they could
defend their country but at the same
time we continue with political pressure
towards russia so that russia would stop
this war which they started and also
would withdraw their military
troops from
ukraine so we are working in two
parallel directions with this regard and
of course i totally understand the
concerns
of president zelinski because what we
see the war is not stopped yet therefore
international community must continue to
work out
opportunities how we can support to end
this war
this war in ukraine will be particularly
alarming for the people of estonia
because estonia is one of the few nato
member states that has direct borders
with russia and when your prime minister
met with the secretary of state anthony
blinken yesterday um she said that um
she is asking to establish a permanent
and meaningful nato forward defense in
the baltic region a permanent defense
because estonia you will be watching
what's going on in ukraine and feeling
particularly vulnerable
yes we have seen
russia's aggressive behavior already for
many years against its neighbors and of
course
this must be reflected also in
documents of nature
in nato
in nato's last year summit it was
jointly agreed that
russia poses threat due to transatlantic
security therefore we started already
last year with these the seasons that we
must continue to strengthen the defense
and endurance posture of nato and from
our perspective yes we need some more
permanent solutions how to defend how to
strengthen the defense posture here in
europe and we believe that we must have
forward defense posture in place
for our region and also we must have
better um air defense systems in place
so we continue to work towards these
solutions within the nato together with
our nato allies
uh foreign minister i know just a a
couple of weeks ago you were in ukraine
you had to cut that visit short so
you've seen the impact of what is
happening on the ground in ukraine but
you have also witnessed over the border
in your country the influx of refugees
perhaps you can talk to us about the
numbers you've received so far
and what's happening when they get to
you what provisions you have from them
because we talk about shelter and the
basics that they need straight away
food and medicine but they also need
jobs they need somewhere to stay because
we don't know how long this is going to
last for what's been the response in
estonia to help them
this is very unfortunate that as of
today we have seen more than 2 million
people already have left ukraine and
they are looking for homes in other
neighboring countries in estonia here we
have accepted by today we have accepted
about 10 000 refugees we have
four refugee centers here in estonia
which register the refugees and then
provide them
places to live most of them
will be
staying with the relatives who were
already here in estonia or friends or
co-workers but if they don't have other
place to stay then we provide hotels for
them for the period of time that there
is another solution found for them of
course at the same time we provide also
uh social security uh and also medical
care because we also see that about the
third of the refugees are children so
they may need different kind of support
and yesterday morning i started my day
also in the refugee center and wanted to
see with my own eyes how this
registration works out and how these
people are helped in estonia and i can
really say that
those people who reach here in estonia
they are warmly welcomed they have been
provided with food with help and
assistance how to organize their life
here in estonia until they can return to
home or transfer to other countries
where they may have relatives of friends
and foreign minister i'll ask you one
final question because this is a hotly
contested topic in the uk at the moment
and
how slowly
the wheels are turning to get ukrainian
refugees a visa to enter the uk just how
quick is the process in estonia how
quickly can people be granted entry into
your country from the time they reach
the border
in estonia ukrainians can enter
visa-free therefore they just
packed into the buses in in mostly in
poland on sometimes in other neighboring
countries and then they are brought to
estonia we have
ngos in place who organize this
transportation and so basically they
don't need any document any documents to
enter estonia but of course here in
estonia we just register them and
provide with
documents also uh phone numbers and
security
uh codes so that they can start their
lives here in estonia